Chực thằng tấn công á hấp sấu tư a gà điên,
khiến bạn nướng tấp hiện đại của dòng á phá trê giò Mỹ sản xuất.
Chực thằng sự hiệu dầu cả tiến mạnh mẽ về hoàn lực,
khả năng cơ động và công hệ để tử.
Á hấp sấu tư a có chêu dài mối bẩy phay bẩy mét,
đường kính lo tốt chính buổi bún phay só mét,
và chêu cám buổi phay só mét,
chọng lượng giấm đặt năng nghìn 1,5 mc xa khí lo gàm,
chọng lượng cắt cạnh tối ra lên đến buổi gình 1,8 mc.
Mấy bai được chăng bị 2 độ cơ tế bẩy chăm,
gờ em hệ không một đe,
bối tầm công xuất bà nhìn kí lo gà,
giúp đặt tức độ tối ra 2,5 mc chiến kí lo mét,
trên rời tâm bai bún chăm bẩy mấy sấu kí lo mét,
và chân bai lên đến sấu gình 1,8 mc.
Á hấp sấu tư a tích hợp ra ra an ở app gờ bẩy chăm,
và hẹn thống quan sát 1 piêu bà đêm an ở app vi một một pên ở vẻ s.
Rà đa có khả năng theo dõi 1,5 mc,
theo cùng lúc và thiêu dịch mười sấu mục tiêu đồng thời,
hăng kưởng đáng kể thành lần át chiến và sấu còn trên chiến chiến chiến chiến gây đại.
Chừng thằng á hát sấu tư a có thể mang theo nhiều lại vụ khi mạnh mẽ như
bảo mờ 2,5 mc em 1,8 mc.
Tốc độ bán sấu chăm 5 mc viên trên tốt, tâm bán 1,5 mc.
Tên lửa á gờ mơ 1 mc bún theo phai, tâm bán lên tới mồi 1 kí lo mét,
dùng để thiêu dịch sẽ tăng và tông chiến kí lo mốt.
Tên lửa ái mơ chính xài ngoài đơ, tâm bán 1,5 mc.
Chủ yếu dùng để thiêu dịch mục tiêu trên không.
Lúc cách khi đờ ra bẩy mời, tâm bán tâm đến 1,5 mc.
Dùng để hội chợ hoàn lực mặt đất với khả năng bán loạn nhiều mục tiêu cùng lúc.
Á hát sấu tư a gà điền, tâm một chực thằng tâm tông tà năng,
mạnh mẽ được thiết kể để sự dịch tham nhìn vụ kiem chợ hoàn lực.
Thìêu dịch mục tiêu mặt đất, và hát chuyến cho nhiều kẹn tốt tâm.